I just can't if I'm being honest it
feels like I'm just stuck in a nightmare
we're going round and round in circles
trying to
piece together what could have possibly
happened
and we've just got to keep such an open
mind with everything because we just
have no idea
where she is it's like she's just
vanished Into Thin Air there's no
evidence to point us in any direction
obviously my hope is that she's still
out there she's Sonic's happened and
she's
I don't know needed to take herself off
for whatever reason and we we just want
a home we need to we need her home her
children need a home
it's just absolutely heartbreaking
only for you
what's the last week been like as a
as a father
it's been very difficult as from last
Friday morning today it's just been so
painful
we're such a close-knit family
we talk to each other
all our both our children Louise and
Nicola and the children every day
there's not a day goes by
without talking to them
and this has just emptied our lives at
the minute we just feel so empty
um you know we appreciate everything
that everyone's doing to find her
the police have been brilliant the local
community has been outstanding
and it's just comforting from that point
of view
but at the end of the day we just we
just want it back on that point you know
the community Spirit has been
unbelievable in a very small village how
much has that helped you knowing that
people have come from far and wide to
help look for your daughter massive
it's been massive we've really
appreciated it and everyone that's been
involved
doing a sweep search of the fields Etc
it's just given us hope that someone
might find something that could give us
that little clue to what might have
happened
we just need to delete we just need
something we're nearly a week on
tomorrow and we'll just go around in
circles it's like some something's got
to have been missed there's there's got
to be somebody must know something
somebody must know
somebody people don't just vanish Into
Thin Air there's got to be somebody that
knows something and all we are asking no
matter how small or big if there's
anything that you can remember that just
doesn't seem right then please reach out
to the police please just get in touch
and
get my sister back I was going to ask
you that Lou what is it you want to say
to people watching this wherever they're
sat wherever they're watching from on
their phones on the Tellies what would
you want to say to people
in order to help you well just if
anybody knows anything just yeah just
let us know just Nikki if you're bloody
Outlet just let us know that you're okay
we can so anything out we can we just
want you home we just want you home yeah
my um my approach to this is that um
for the public
to search their minds or
anything that they might have seen
doesn't matter how significant it is
if it's if it's um
something that they think might not be
interesting it could be
and inform the police
that that they've seen something
but the main thing is that um you know
we want to find Nicola
get her back home
there's two young children there waiting
to for their mummy to come back
and we feel that we want to back
obviously also
but you know if Nicola is out there if
she's watching this
then always like to say is
just come home
contact the police contact ourselves
and we just want you back one thing I'm
covering this story and speaking to
people right at the very heart of it and
everyone harks back to this is that
there are two beautiful girls
at home
Nikki's kids
you know how difficult is that knowing
that
the daughters are there without a mom
it was just they say obviously they
their little minds are trying to process
they don't
really understand but none of us
understand to be honest
um
but we've just got to try and
when there's children involved you have
to carry on you've got to get through
every day and
that's that's all we're trying to do but
they know mum is missing
um but they know that she's going to be
coming home
um
and this is um
everyone's looking for her
so it's only a matter of time that
they're thinking in their minds that
she's gonna walk through that door
what happened on Friday morning was
started off as what seemed to be Nikki's
you know daily routine really dropping
the kids off of school taking Willow for
a walk it all seemed quite normal but
how do you feel about
the fact that this has happened and it
it is a Nikki in a way if you get what I
mean it's not her it's not normal Nicki
no what what's happened how does that
make you feel well we just haven't got
any answers
she's done this a thousand times
dropped the children off from school
I'd be like a dog Willow she loves it to
bits that dog
should do anything for the animal
she Parks the car in the in the school
car park walks across the past Michael's
Church
through that little lane up to the open
field and that's where she does it every
day day in day out there may be days
where she misses but if it's not her
it's Paul and it all revolves around the
point that they've dropped the children
off at the school
but it's just routine and you know
we're just baffled by it
just baffled
because at least the police only have
said that you know they're keeping an
open mind about what's happened here is
is that is that easy to do is it
difficult to keep an open mind you know
when that you know there's speculation
and everything how how tough is that
yeah well we're trying to be quite
honest with you we're trying not to get
too involved in what people are saying
because nobody knows anything do they so
and that's what we really want to say
today is don't get blindsided that this
has definitely happened or you know we
need to keep an open mind could be
anything because there's no evidence to
point any other way and
get my sister home
we'll just end on
if I don't know from from you all and
how important is it that this message
is out there that people listen that
they give any information that they
possibly can to help get your sister to
help get your daughter back home how
crucial is it right now well it's you
see anything we're holding on to we're
holding on to this is um not our last
hope but this is going to reach out to
millions of people
and we're just hoping that from this
interview
that Summit may come of it which will
spark a lot
and it will lead to us finding our
daughter
how much are you missing now popped out
but see it's old
we have such a
a closely apparently we are we are
closest Family sorry
but we're at such a close-knit family we
do anything for any one of us and the
children would do the same for us we're
we're getting on in life
and you know the grandchildren and their
own children are more and more important
to us as we're getting older
so
yeah just hope she comes out